welcome back losing weight can be tough
and everyone loses weight in different
ways
dr nash recognizes this and you can see
it in her clients success stories
dr nash welcome to the show and this is
one of my favorite segments this is when
you bring your success stories to show
all of us
and it's just the tip of the iceberg of
your success stories but
the one i want to start with and it's
the one i love the most is your success
story
30 pounds 12 years ago how did you do it
so i struggled with obesity for 25 years
of my life always looking for an answer
always going to experts and never really
getting
a long lasting result and it's because
there was metabolic damage there was
stuff going on inside me that was
sabotaging me
by addressing and identifying what that
damage was and correcting it
that got me to lose the 80 pounds and
that's what allows me to hold the weight
loss eating two to three thousand
calories a day
we got a video here everybody take a
look at becky
i lost 42 pounds on dr nash's program
i'm seven pounds away
from my goal if i can do this i can do
anything what i love about becky is that
there's you see the weight loss but
she looks like a younger person yeah she
does
and becky was absolutely stumped with
why her body wasn't responding in fact
one of my
previous clients had found her in a
classroom sobbing because she couldn't
figure out
why everything she was trying was not
working with her body and that's when
the client called me
to step in and help her and as a result
over 40 pounds of weight loss and she
just
radiates health and vibrancy it's
amazing
you can see it you can just see it it
comes across the screen all right
everybody
take a look at laura when i started with
dr nash i weighed over 300 pounds and i
was pre-diabetic
since being on a program i lost over 130
pounds
and i no longer have that pre-diabetic
threat laura's results i mean you must
be so proud of laura
and the journey and and her weight loss
accomplishments
laura lost jc almost
yeah and laura was somebody that thought
that her problem was hormonal but she
thought it was menopause
and it wasn't the menopause hormones it
was the dietary hormone so once we got
those adjusted
her body went from burning body fat only
30 percent of the time
to burning body fat more than 75
of the time and she lost 134 pounds
take a look at meredith now the thing i
i notice about meredith here is you
really see the change in meredith's
stomach
so if we're seeing exceeding amounts of
belly fat that is usually a big
visual clue from the body that we are
dealing with damage in fact
meredith had the same problem that 61 of
americans have had since the
pandemic which was a weight gain and she
had gained over 35 pounds
she decided to work on that body during
the pandemic and instead she dropped the
35 pounds and what you see is the most
significant
is the change to the belly that means
we're fixing the damage underneath
incredible dr nash every week you bring
an incredible special to the show what
do you got for us this week
so of course normally if people want to
talk to me and do the evaluation to find
out if this type of damage is going on
in them it's 97
but when i go on las vegas now with jc
and i talk about it
we always have a few spots available for
9.97
it's 90 percent off of the normal price
but you have to lock it in by going to
the website